bonjour je vous donne rendez-vous cette
semaine le jeudi 21 mai pour un nouveau
numéro de fileco votre magazine
d'actualité qui revient sur l'économie
locale au programme de cette édition le
14e forum entreprise et défense il se
tient à Versailles cette semaine et
rassemble plus de 300 exposants du
secteur de l'industrie de la défense
nous vous ferons découvrir cet événement
nous irons également aux technocentre de
Renault à Guyancourt pour assister à la
finale nationale des Olympiades de
sciences de l'ingénieur qui rassemble
plus de 300 lycéens enfin dans notre
partie magazine portrait de Christophe
Robin éleveur de volailles à sonchamps
il a été désigné meilleur agriculteur du
territoire Île-de-France et dans notre
entretien de la semaine nous parlerons
de localement vôtre donc s'il y a un an
ce site internet fait découvrir tous les
créateurs et producteurs ivinois nous
reviendrons sur cette initiative avec sa
créatrice pour retrouver tout ce
reportage et ne rien manquer de votre
actualité économique locale rendez-vous
cette semaine dans Philippo